[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
hello again walter good day we said we
were going to talk about this
issue right yes it's very relevant
very current so we have to get into it
let's open with a word of rare our
heavenly father thank you so much for
bringing us
again together we ask that you please
bless the
discussion bless the viewers and also
help us to discern
the things that is happening in the
world in jesus name amen
yes we have a new encyclical out
and we mentioned it in the last episode
and i think we just have to briefly
go through it and see what this is all
about
because deception is the name of the
game isn't it
yes in the world and we're going to
expose the master deceiver today
we are going to try it's not an easy
task
because he's he's very good at what he
does exactly
so this is uh pope francis's latest
encyclical
and this comes from the vatican webpage
encyclical letter
fratelli tutti of the holy father
francis on fraternity and
social friendship in actual fact
this is a document
on catholic social doctrine but it's
very well disguised
very well disguised so let us jump
right into it here is an article in
crooks
that just appeared and it comes from
october 6
2020 where bishop michael
cerney gives his opinion on this
encyclical its title
cardinal says pope's new encyclical is a
warning
the world is on the brink so this
is almost like climate change you know
everything's on the brink
everything has to change right now
there's a deadline there's a deadline
one of pope francis's top advisers said
that the pontiff sees the current world
situation
comparable to that of the cuban missile
crisis
world war ii or 911 and that to fully
understand the papal
encyclical released on sunday it's
necessary to acknowledge
we're on the brink so
this is this is a common trend
in what we're doing today what's
happening in the world
depending on your age what was it like
to hear
pius xii deliver his christmas messages
during world war
ii said cardinal michael cerney on
monday
or how did it feel when pope john the
23rd
published parsem in terres or after 2007
crisis it's interesting how they mention
these events right yeah or after 9 11
and i think you need to recover that
feeling in your stomach and your whole
being to appreciate
fratelli tutti
okay he continues
i think pope francis feels today the
world needs a message
comparable to what we needed during the
cuban missile crisis
or world war ii 911
or the big crash of 2007
2008. now it's interesting
that we said in the past that this crash
was very important because it changed
the world economy correct
it totally changed the world economy and
that's important
because it actually brought the world
economy closer to the papal system
yes it just needs tweaking now
he said we're on the brink we need to
pull back in a very
human worldwide and local way
and i think that's one way to get
into fratelli tutti this gives a very
good background
of the setting for this encyclical
according to the cardinal if pope
francis's previous
encyclical laudato si on the care of
creation taught us that everything is
connected
fratelity teaches us that everyone
is connected so we're moving from
the environment environmental global
issues
to the human issues
if we take responsibility for our common
home
and for our brothers and sisters then i
think that we do
have a good chance and my hope is
rekindled and inspired to keep on going
and do more he said
we're on an express train
yes
cerny argued that it's not the role of
church leaders not even the pope
to tell us how to run our economy and or
our politics
however that's the important word right
the pope can guide the world towards
certain
values and this is what the pope does
in his latest encyclical issuing a
reminder that the economy
cannot be in the driver's seat of
politics
so he's going to give the moral
directive
as to where we are going with this thing
now i actually read the encyclical
and i think we should just read a few
things we're not going to go through the
entire encyclical it would take us a
very long time
but just a few highlights
before we continue with this encyclical
i have to say that it's written
in a very flowery language
but hidden in that language there are
certain
points which become
very important for the world we are
living in
and it has a much deeper root
than appears on the first look
so this is the encyclical and we will
scroll
down through the encyclical
and he starts with fratelli tutti
with these words so saint francis of a
addressed his brothers and sisters
and proposed to them a way of life
marked by the flavor of the gospel
of the councils francis offered i would
like to select the one
in which he calls for a love that
transcends the barriers of geography
and distance and declares blessed
all those who love their brother as much
as when he is far away from him as when
he
is with him so he starts with us so his
role model
is saint francis of assisi now i have a
problem with that
from the word go because my role model
is jesus christ and that would be
the starting point where i would start
but for a roman catholic i guess
the saint is a is a better interpreter
but it's also because they put them on
par with jesus
correct so now let's just read
some of the statements we're not going
to read too many just
a few of them
point number two he says this saint of
fraternal love
simplicity and joy who inspired me to
write the
encyclical lauda to see so he refers
back to loda
to see you cannot separate the two so
the one deals with the environment the
other
one deals with humanity and the two have
to go
together prompts me once more to
devote this new encyclical to fraternity
and
social friendship francis felt himself a
brother
to the son the sea and the wind
yet he knew that he was even closer to
those of his own flesh
now my young brother what is that
pantheism
pantheism at his best who was lauda to
see
speckled with pantheism yes this is a
pantheistic religion
it is an earthbound pantheistic religion
where man
sets himself up as his own deity
this is a very dangerous dangerous
opening statement
wherever he went he sowed seeds of peace
and walked alongside the poor the
abandoned the infirm
and the outcast the least of his
brothers
and sisters now this sets the tone
for catholic social doctrine
christ came to save all
of humanity and jesus said
the poor will be with you always
and there are discrepancies in the world
which are not fair
but the way in which they use the
situation
which they often create themselves
is what is scary
and then he starts off by talking about
without
borders no borders no we don't have to
go into great detail we know that donald
trump was very strict on borders
and that there was a problem there
with borders so he goes into this he
even talks about
walls and and all of these issues
he says francis did not wage a war of
words
aimed at imposing doctrines
he simply spread the love of god he
understood that god
is love and those who abide in love
abide in god
quoting 1 john 4 16 in this way he
became a
father to all and inspired the vision of
a fraternal society
now the problem with this sentence is
that this is how many people believe
today
all you need is to preach about the love
of jesus
nothing else or maybe just love
and leave out jesus yes
and that doctrines are a problem
that's why francis did not wage a war of
words
aimed at imposing doctrines because it
causes division it causes division
and pope francis said take away the
doctrine right
so they don't want doctrine they want
their social theology yes
now their social theology will only work
of course
if there are enough poor people that
they can get on board
so the poorer they can make society the
more likely they are to succeed
in getting the power that they want yes
this is a very dangerous precedent
now again he refers to
in the preparation of to see
i had a source of inspiration in my
brother batholymu
the orthodox patriarch and he says he
had
this grand imam ahmad
al tayeb he was also a source of
inspiration and we met in
abu dhabi and the present encyclical
takes up and develops some of the great
themes raised in the document that the
imam
and he signed together so this has all
been prepared
beforehand and the
mega religions of the world seem to be
on board
yes that's a muslim have you ever been
to the middle east have you ever been
to these countries in the middle east
well there you have a massive divide
between the rich and the poor so it is a
it is a very fertile ground for
a catholic social doctrine yes so as
would be poorer countries third world
countries whether they be in africa
whether they be in south america the
target
is protestant countries
that have developed a form of
affluence which is not compatible with
the rest of the world
and that has to be brought down because
that is the way in which you control
humanity right now
if you understand this then you will see
where they're actually heading
of course he has to bring in the covet
19 pandemic
and the reasons why we need rapid change
anyone who thinks that the only lesson
to be learned was the need to
improve what we were already doing
or to refine existing systems and
regulations
is denying reality we need change
the new normal yeah the great reset we
have to go to the great reset
it's interesting he doesn't mention any
specific legislation
he doesn't tout sunday or any one of
those
he did that before yes he's just
emphasizing
the dow to c and that's been done there
already it's been done so we don't have
to go
there so if we continue
and here he has again this theme let us
dream them
as a single human family
this is a globalist agenda
this is a one world government
agenda this is the papal agenda
how much of the world does he want to
control the whole world
how much of the world must fall in with
his philosophy
well everybody everybody now
if we take the trump campaign and we
take the biden campaign
which one is more in line with the new
world order idea
the biden camp right uh
that that's becoming very interesting to
me because as we discussed last time you
know there are king of the north
elements in both of them
and both of them stand for catholicism
and
as we dealt with in in the last
discussion
but this pope and the papacy in general
dreams of world dominance yes
world dominance a1 world
order and the donald trump philosophy
although church and state is very strong
in that philosophy which is part of the
roman philosophy it's not very strong on
the one world
government philosophy more nationalists
so dark clouds over a closed world
shattered dreams and it continues on
that issue
and he says ancient conflicts thought
long buried or breaking out anew
while instances of myopic extremist
resentful and aggressive nationalism on
the rise who's he referring to
trump trump in some countries the
concept of popular
and national unity influenced by various
ideologies is creating
new forms of selfishness and the loss of
social sense and the guise of defending
national interests so obviously we have
this clash right
thesis antithesis synthesis
what's interesting with this clash as
well is a lot of people see
trump as the hero because he's going to
get rid of this new world order
but here he's touting it the pope is
touting it if you take the q
and on story there are so many that are
pinning their hopes
social media has banned all cue and non
mentions lately they also stated of
course that the present pope will be
removed and that ratzinger will
again take over but he's so old now
i think this is all a pipe dream there
will be a synthesis
somewhere along the line so
yes so they're working on this issue
let's continue
he's very persistent that there seems to
be a plan lacking for
everyone we need a global governance
and we don't have to go into the guys
he's talking about
brotherly love and love for each other
and
love for our differences
evangelism is totally
out of the picture we're all supposed to
live
side by side happily acknowledging that
the other one
is just as much in the truth as as we
are yes
but the gospel is totally different
the gospel says go and go to every
tongue and nation and even and make
disciples make disciples
and this is totally out in this new
world
order he talks about the throwaway world
we don't have to read
all of this in such flowery language
he talks about insufficiency of
universal human rights
and the rights of women and all the
things
slavery all of these issues he mentions
them
and conflict and fear of humanity
and temptation to build a culture of
walls now where does that come from yeah
from trump
it's trump he talks about walls to raise
walls walls in the heart walls on the
land
in order to prevent this encounter with
other cultures with other people
he wants to integrate humanity into
one mixture no borders nothing
now who separated the cultures
oh god okay did that mean that god
wanted to
isolate cultures no obviously not
because you had to evangelize
you had to get to know people but god
acknowledged
that there were differences and these
differences must all disappear
i'm not against immigration or migration
if people are saying i'm just
generally saying what the what the will
of the papacy is
so globalization and progress without a
shared
roadmap won't work you need a shared
roadmap
but we have to get to the to the
nitty-gritty of this document
he says here in today's world the sense
of belonging to a single human
family is fading and the dream of
working together for
justice and peace seems an outdated
utopia
what reigns instead is a cool
comfortable
and globalized indifference born of
deep disillusionment concealed behind a
deceptive illusion
thinking that we are all powerful while
failing to realize that we are all
in the same boat sounds very good right
very good where is it going to lead
and he talks about pandemics and other
calamities in history
true a worldwide tragedy like the covet
19 pandemic
momentarily revived the sense that we
are a real
global community all in the same boat
where one person's problems are the
problems of all
once more we realize that no one is
saved alone
we can only be saved together
sure that's interesting collective
salvation
is there such a thing in the bible no no
you can only work out your own salvation
work out your
own salvation with fear and trembling
so what they're really talking about is
getting rid of your individuality
for the sake of the common good yeah
as i said in those days the storm has
exposed our vulnerability and
uncovered those false and superfluous
certainties around which we constructed
our daily schedules our projects our
habits and our priorities
amid this storm the facade of those
stereotypes with which we camouflaged
our egos
always worrying about appearances has
fallen away
revealing once more the inelutable and
blessed awareness
that we are part of one another that we
are brothers
and sisters of one another we're all
one communism
has everybody even wearing the same
clothes
driving the same car driving the same
car
everything is the same individuality
is something that must be faded out
if you look at human appearances are
there two people that are alike even
twins are they absolutely the same
no so is god a god of variety
or is god a god of singularity variety
okay and they they mix up the
oneness that jesus talks about
with their human that's a very good
point
yes that you that oneness is
one in purpose in terms of
faith of where we come from who saves
us and where we are going
now we don't have to read all he has to
say
about all of these things his point here
in 35
all too quickly however we forget the
lessons of history
the teacher of life once this health
crisis
passes our worst response would be to
plunge
even more deeply into feverish
consumerism
and new forms of egotistic
self-preservation
god willing after all this we will think
no longer of terms of
them and those but only us
if only this may prove not to be just
another tragedy of history
from which we have learned nothing this
covert
is going to be used to the uttermost to
achieve an
objective there's new normal there's a
new normal
an absence of human dignity on the
borders
certain populist political regimes as
well as certain
liberal economic approaches maintain
that an
influx of migrants is to prev prevent it
at all costs who is he talking about
again
the united states the united states
and any other country that refuses to
take migrants yes
yeah the big issue in europe a big one
in in germany
all over the world this is a major issue
but the pope has always maintained
that we have to have migrants we have to
mix the cultures
i'm wondering whether he wants to mix
cultures
or whether he wants to mix religions
because cultures come with religions
migration more than ever before will
play a pivotal role
in the future of our world he's going
to mix he's going to mix
definitely yet it is also true that an
individual and a people are only
fruitful and productive
if they are able to develop a creative
openness
to others we have to mix
shameless aggression
this is now given free reign to
ideologies
things that until a few years ago could
not be said by anyone without risking
the loss of universal respect
can now be said with impunity and in the
crudest of terms
even by some political figures who's he
referring to
it's getting boring right it's a one-way
conversation the whole time it looks
like towards
trump yeah it is definitely alluding
to he should have he should have said
that um
not only francis of assisi was inspiring
to write this yes absolutely there's
another one here
article 46 here we should also recognize
that destructive forms of fanaticism
are at times found amongst religious
believers
including christians he likes to throw
that
in there and what was his greatest gripe
with
christians the christian funder
fundamentalists
true bible believers true bible
believers
and they define it anybody who believes
in a literal creation
who believes that jesus atoned for our
sins
etc yes who believes in the literal
resurrection
all of those issues they are the enemy
of the world they're terrorists so
including christians they too
can be caught up in networks of verbal
violence through the internet and
various forums of
digital communication i wonder whether
he's talking about
us even in catholic media
limits can be overstepped i think he's
talking about
the church militant the church militant
defamation and slander can become
commonplace
and all ethical standards and respect
for the good name of others can be
abandoned
how can this contribute to the
fraternity of our common father
asks us but jesus said
i have not come to bring peace but a
sword yeah so the gospel will bring
variance
he's cutting out the gospel very
important
there's no room for the gospel in his
fraternity
that's why jesus christ is not the norm
saint francis becomes the norm
information without wisdom
forms of subjection and self-contempt
and hope and very flowery language and
then he
he discusses in great detail the good
samaritan
but he totally misses the point of who
the good samaritan is
the good samaritan is jesus christ
and what did jesus christ do when he
came across
this poor battered man he was on a
journey
all the others that had passed by had
come
down from jerusalem
and they ignored this man lying there
but the good samaritan went up to him
and
gave him oil and wine
and dressed his wounds with that
the oil is a symbol of the holy spirit
the wine is the symbol
of teaching of doctrine yes doctrine
so he gave him wine and he gave him
doctrine because the church had
neglected him
and then he put him on his own donkey
his own means of transport and he took
him to an
inn a very strange inn because it was
also a hospital
it's a symbol of the church and then he
said to
the innkeeper here is some money
it's interesting that he gave him two
pants
two pence and said
i'm going away but when i come again
i will reward you but here's the money
that is necessary to take care
of these neglected ones
in the hospital the church now just for
interest sake
a penny was a day's wages so he gave him
two days wages i let the people think
about that for themselves
because in cosmic weak thinking a day
would be a thousand years but let's not
go there we'll get into trouble
but it's an interesting interesting
thought so he has this story about
you know this poor man and the good
samaritan
and he doesn't make jesus the good
we become the good samaritans
so we're going to skip his long story
on the good samaritan
where he talks about all of these issues
it's interesting
that the imams and everybody was so
interested
in this encyclical and then there's this
interesting
heading neighbors without borders
this is definitely globalism on a grand
scale envisaging
and engendering an open world
yeah this is new world order stuff right
again he has the topic here open
societies that
integrate everyone
inadequate understandings of universal
love
love capable of transcending borders
is the basis of what in every city and
country
can be called social friendship
genuine social friendship within a
society
makes true universal openness possible
he's obviously referring to catholic
social
doctrine and we'll see he gets to the
point
a little bit later in his encyclical
now what is the role of the church
according to the pope
it's to promote moral values
now in his case whose moral values
his own his own the churches right not
the biblical ones
so he writes nor can we fail to mention
that seeking and pursuing the good of
others
and of the entire human family also
implies helping individuals and
societies to mature
in the moral values that foster integral
human development now those moral values
come from the papacy he's building up
yeah he's building up he writes
regrettably i feel bound to reiterate
that we've had enough of immorality
and the mockery of ethics goodness faith
and honesty
it is time to acknowledge that
light-hearted
superficiality has done us no good
once the foundations of social life are
corroded
what ensues are battles over conflicting
interests let us return to promoting the
good
what good common good common good
for ourselves and for the whole human
family and thus advance together towards
an authentic and
integral growth every society
needs to ensure that values are passed
on
otherwise what is handed down are
selfishness
violence corruption in its various forms
indifferent and ultimately a life close
to transcendence and entrenched in
individual interests individuality must
go
we need common values common good
it's like you said in the previous
episode the free
freedom of religion is just
as long as it coincides with common good
absolutely and if we do not understand
this
this buttery language in which it is
written
will confuse people if you don't
understand the agenda behind
papal thinking you will miss the point
of what he is writing
when we speak of the need to care for
our common home
our planet we appeal to that spark of
universal
consciousness and mutual concern that
may still be present
in people's hearts that's
common good yeah and universal
consciences
sounds almost a little bit new age it's
it's very new age
it's very new agenda spark of universal
conscience
those who enjoy a surplus of water yet
choose to conserve it for the sake of
the greater human family have attained a
moral
stature that allows them to look beyond
themselves
and the group to which they belong how
marvelously human
the same attitude is demanded if we are
to recognize the rights of
all people even those born beyond our
borders
again this is humanism
god is left out of the picture and the
morality
that leads you to do something good
comes from within humanity which is new
edge thinking
exactly and not necessary very new age
indeed
not biblical at all
the common destination of created goods
now it gets interesting this led them to
realize that if one person
lacks what is necessary to live with
dignity
it because another person is detaining
it
this is a very interesting way of
thinking so if you have something and
another person doesn't have
you are at fault because you have not
the other person because he doesn't
bother to attain it
well there are some that can't attain it
and they have to be taken care of
true but this is typical
social doctrine of the roman catholic
church
saint john christ islam summarizes it in
this way
not to share our wealth with the poor is
to rob them
and take away their livelihood
in other words if you own something you
are a thief
[Music]
the riches we possess are not our own
but theirs
as well in the words of saint gregory
the great when we provide the needy with
their basic
needs we are giving them what belongs to
them not to us
no this is not biblical thinking
if you provide the needy with the means
to be able to take care of themselves if
you educate
people if you give them incentives to
work and to attain
then they don't have to find the riches
in someone else's house this
is a reflection of
navarro we will talk about that in a
moment
this is catholic social thinking
[Music]
at its best or in my opinion at its
worst i quote john paul ii
well there's a shrine in the united
states to him
and donald trump visited that shrine i
wonder whether he's so happy with the
theology
of pope john paul he mentioned in the
previous episode in that video
that that actually is yeah that is very
strange for my part
i would observe that the christian
tradition
has never recognized the right to
private property
as absolute or inviolable
okay this is catholic social doctrine we
will go into that
and i stress the social purpose of all
forms of
private property in roman catholic
thinking you
are allowed to possess property but the
property is not your own
it is there for social advancement
if you take it to an extreme case like
they do
in some countries in the world if you
own a piece of land
and others have need of it they may
occupy it
it's your social duty than to provide it
because you possess it
it's probably also your social duty to
continue paying the dues on the land
now this gets very interesting
so it says the common use of created
goods is the first
principle of the whole ethical and
social order
now this is very fascinating so if you
own
something you only own it for the social
good i once worked for an institution
that gave me a cell phone because we
needed to communicate it
but the cell phone was a social grant
so anyone else who stopped you and
needed
the cell phone you had to give it to
them
but the bill came to you that's
interesting
you're very yeah so nothing you own is
actually yours if you don't love the car
it's not your car if someone has need of
it you can take it
it is natural and inherent right that
takes priority over others
all other rights having to do with the
goods necessary for the integral
fulfillment of persons
including that of private property or
any other type of property
should in the words of saint paul vi
in no way hinder this right but should
actively facilitate its implementation
you don't own anything he's referring to
the encyclicals of
pope john paul ii he is referring to the
encyclicals of paul vi
we'll have to have a quick look at those
in no way hinder this right but should
actively facilitate its implementation
the right to private property
can only be considered a secondary
natural right
derived from the principle of the
universal destination of created goods
this has concrete consequences that
ought to be reflected in the workings of
society
yet it often happens that secondary
rights displace primary and overriding
rights and practice making them
irrelevant
so you you you're using your property
for your own
but it's a bad thing it's a it's that's
that's a no-no
in catholic thinking now in in the
middle ages
had the clergy and then they had the
elite
the elite were the land owners and the
serfs
occupied the land but they didn't
own the land so we're going to head for
a similar system under this order so a
major company
will provide the housing and you become
basically a slave to the company
that the company then takes the place
of the elite land owners of
ancient times the
nobles so we have the same
system system rights without borders
no one then can remain excluded because
of his or
her place of birth much less because
of privileges enjoyed by others who were
born in lands of greater opportunity
the limits and borders of individual
states cannot stand in the way of this
so if you have become a rich nation
because you
are a hard-working people
then you have to give that away to the
poorer people
you have to this is catholic social
doctrine
everybody has to be equal any head that
pops up above the others
should be lopped off yeah
development must not aim at the amassing
of
wealth by a few but must ensure human
rights
personal and social economic and
political
including the rights of nations and of
people so what applies to the individual
applies to the nations so
capitalism in all its forms must
disappear
the alternative is the state owns
everything
and that is according to catholicism
also not right
so we have thesis we have
antithesis let's put it political
we have trump we have biden both of them
are wrong
both of them are wrong we need a
synthesis
church and state church and stay
together
you have private property but only
under a social mortgage
and anything that you own is not
yours interesting in the
previous episode biden said
that he lives by the social doctrine
of the roman catholic church now bernie
sanders
yes bernie sanders
was boasting about the fact
that he went to the vatican and there
took part in these discussions of
economics and he was boasting
that his philosophy is the catholic
social philosophy
and the americans looked at him and said
this man is extreme
they haven't seen anything yet they
haven't seen anything yet
but let's continue this just another
thing that was came coming to mind now
amy only barrett belongs to that
group people of praise yes and according
to the articles
they already also have a sort of social
everything belongs to everybody they
share their
absolutely thing absolutely so
catholic social doctrine when that
becomes the norm
we will realize where this is really
leading we'll talk about it in a moment
so the right to private property is
always accompanied by the primary and
prior principle
of the subordination of all private
property
to the universal destination of
earth goods and thus the right of all to
their use
you have nothing now
is this biblical no no
do we have a story in the bible where
a government wanted to
take away the land of a private land
owner
do you remember the story of ahab
and nabot's vineyard and
ahab wanted the vineyard
and ahab said i want this vineyard
and nobody said to him i'm sorry
this is my inheritance
from whom from god from god
this is my god-given right
it is not yours
do you remember who said to him don't
worry i'll get it for you
jezebel jezebel and jezebel
serves as a type of womb the roman
catholic church how do we know because
if you go to the middle church
in the book of revelation there is
jezebel who is tolerated by the church
she is dealing in purple and
red the colors of the roman catholic
church she is the one
who says i'll get it for you
so who's my dear the king of jezebel
jezebel
jezebel his countenance was sad the
bible says
and jezebel what did she do
she had him murdered she killed him
so do you think governments can
sometimes sanction
the killing of people who own land yes
do you think it could happen
by whose instigation the church by
jezebel
yeah so this is what we're seeing here
and it states here quite clearly that
the bishops of the united states have
been teaching this
as the bishops of the united states have
taught
there are fundamental rights that pros
precede any society because they flow
from the dignity granted to each person
as created by god
this is the common good
and this is natural law
natural law he writes what applies to
nations is true also for different
regions within a country since there too
are great inequalities that often exist
so this is a universal rule
a universal law then he talks about
debt in many instances debt repayments
not only fails to
promote development but gravely limits
and conditions it
while respecting the principles that all
legitimately require
debt must be repaid the way in which
many poor countries fulfill
this obligation should not end up
compromising their very existence and
growth
in actual fact he is pleading
for the total abolishment of all debt
the united nations his speech he
addressed he said please
get rid of it especially 19 situation
now where did money much of that relief
money that went to the poor nations go
to where did it go to
did it go to the people or to go to the
pockets of the leaders
pockets borders and their limits our
response to the arrival of migrating
persons can be summarized
by four words welcome protect promote
integrate same story
i'm not against migration but if it is
a migration in order to
rob those who have
and appropriate it for yourself as a
right
then that is called in the bible
stealing
it's against the commandments of god
this whole encyclical
is against the commandments of god
but it's being praised because it's got
such buttery language of love and
kindness
and it's under the garb of love your
neighbor absolutely
but it's a distortion of love your
neighbour the arrival of those who are
different
coming from other ways of life and
culture can be a gift
for the stories of migrants are always
stories of an encounter
between individuals and between cultures
there's nothing wrong with migration
nothing wrong with it at all
but when you migrate in order
to take to take
then you have a problem here he speaks
about latino culture that can
you know ferment the values and
possibilities that can enrich the united
states that's all fair enough
but the agenda behind the agenda is to
mix the religions
to bring in more catholics so that the
catholic vote
will swing the thinking
he said it should be kept in mind that
an innate
tension exists between globalization and
localization we need to pay attention to
the global
so as to avoid the narrowness and
banality
is pushing for the global agenda
this is the papal agenda
a universal horizon there's a kind of
local
narcissism unrelated to a healthy love
of one's
own people and culture it is born of a
certain
insecurity and fear of the others that
leads to rejection and the desire to
erect
walls for self-offense so it is becoming
a criminal offence to have a particular
culture
so if you are a german and you have a
german culture
that has to disappear if it's not for
the common good
it has to go it has to go
so very interesting encyclical
in fact a healthy openness never
threatens one's
own identity but what if the people
threaten those that are living
in the country and then it asks in
chapter five
for a better kind of politics
the development of a global community of
fraternity
based on the practice of social
friendship on the part of peoples and
nations calls for a better kind of
politics
one truly of the service of the common
good
sadly politics today often takes the
forms that
hinder progress towards a different
world
we are heading for a new world
order and when the kings of the world
give their power unto this beast they
will
find out what the purposes of rome
really
were and it will be too late yes
i find it interesting that he refers to
the crisis
2007 2008
provided an opportunity to develop a new
economy
let's just think about that new economy
what was this new economy what happened
there
well the whole world was in debt and
felt uh and they had to
bail everybody out so who bailed out who
the government governments bailed out
industry with billions of dollars right
okay did the government have the money
no
so how do you bail out someone if you
don't have the money to bail them out
with
so they created the money right and they
bailed them out they printed money okay
now let's just
let's just think about this and let the
listeners
contemplate this issue it's a very
interesting issue
prior to the 2007-2008 crisis
there was private property and there was
the government
private industry and the government this
was the first move
to get rid of this individuality
so when the governments bailed out the
industry was it in the form of a loan or
was it
in the form of a buy-in buy-in
so the loans didn't have to be repaid
yes
so now what happened post-2007
2008 is that government and industry
became partners
why was it necessary that they become
partners
so that the community would not suffer
right
otherwise everything would have
collapsed the community would have
suffered
so government and industry in
partnership with
each other for the sake of community
that's the definition of fascism
that's the fascist system of government
and that is the
government system that rome wants so the
first step
to achieving this world global
economic order was the 2007
and seven 2008 economic crash
because it brought in a form of
universal
fascism economically speaking we're not
talking about
the trimmings of fascism that's
something else
very fascinating so it was to develop
a new economy now we'll deal with that
in a moment
i would also insist that to give to each
his
own to cite the classic definition of
justice
means that no human individual or group
can consider itself
absolute no group
entitled to bypass the dignity and the
rights of
other individuals of their social
groupings
so you can't have your own identity you
may not
no now what if you are a religious
identity
that is different from the rest you'll
have to you'll have to change
you'll have to change the effective
distribution of power especially
political economic defence related and
technological power amongst the
plurality of subjects
and the creation of a judicial system
for regulating claims and interests are
one concrete way of limiting power
very interesting so you're not allowed
to be an
individual i would also note the need
for a reform of the united nations
organization
he's a very busy man
and likewise of economic institutions
and international
finance so that the concept of the
family of nations
can acquire real teeth
we're heading somewhere yeah we're
heading somewhere
courage and generosity are needed in
order freely to establish shared goals
and to ensure a worldwide
observance of essential norms
what does that mean i wonder
whether catholic morality and
catholic worship of the sun god are
included
in the special norm essential norm
it did say so in la da to see
to which he referred to many many times
and it seems as if your individual or
group identity will have to give way
to this new norm
much need to change through fundamental
reform and
major renewal only healthy politics
involving the most diverse sectors and
skills is capable of overseeing this
process
i wonder whether he is setting himself
up as the master
puppet man the moral leader
the moral leader of the world we need
political love
in order to do this now let's get to the
nitty-gritty at a time when various
forms of
fundamentalist intolerance are damaging
relationship
between individuals groups and peoples
any idea we could be talking about
let us be committed to living and
teaching the values
of respect for each other a love capable
of welcoming differences
and the priority of the dignity of every
human being over his and hers
ideas opinions practices
and even sins even as forms of
fanaticism close-mindedness
social and cultural fragmentation
proliferate in present-day society
a good politician will take the first
step and insist that different voice
voices be heard
disagreements may well give rise to
conflicts but uniformity
proves stifling and leads to cultural
decay
may we not be content with being
enclosed in one fragment of reality
so if you have a particular religious
norm
you better shape up
or ship out yes in this regard the grand
imam
and i have called upon the architects of
the international policy and the world
economy
to work strenuously to spread the
culture of tolerance and living together
in peace
it sounds very good the two major
religions he's talking about he's
talking about the two major religions
when one part of society exploits all
that the world has to offer
acting as if the poor did not exist they
will eventually be consequences
sooner or later ignoring the existence
and rights of others will erupt in some
forms of
violence often when least expected
now my brother did you create the
poverty in this world
no did you come to the world this world
very rich or did you come to this world
like everyone else
everyone else did you have to work to
achieve
whatever you have achieved in life is it
your fault if
governments or systems suppress others
this is a very one-sided view
of the world so
let's continue i find it interesting
that he says
truth in fact is an inseparable
companion of justice and mercy which is
of course true but whose truth is he
talking about
the church not about the truth of the
bible
at the cross justice and mercy kissed
each other
that's where you find truth truth is
found
in jesus christ and in his word and in
his law
this is absolutely counter to everything
that the bible
stands for well i must just say the
roman church
yeah not just church correct correct
that's what we're talking about
and he refers to the bishops of south
africa he's is bringing in the whole
world
in an integrated form
in point 275 he says it should be
acknowledged that amongst the most
important causes of the crisis of the
modern world
are a desensitized human conscience
a distancing from religious values and
the prevailing
individualism
accompanied by materialistic
philosophies that
deify the human person and introduce
worldly and material values
in place of supreme and trans dental
principles it's interesting
that human conscience has been
desensitized by whom
isn't that by the media yeah do you
think hollywood played a part
yes so jesuit theater played a part in
this
so you create the crisis
you create the chaos and then out of the
chaos
you create your new order world
order
[Music]
very interesting individualism has to go
and it's linked to religious values
religion whose religious values the
roman church
the roman church but if i'm also reading
this right
it says you're not you're prevailing
prevailing individualism
yeah so you're not allowed to have your
individual religion
no you have to you have to serve the
common good
freedom of religion is only
valid as long as it serves the common
good
and who determines the common good the
roman catholic church
that's why it says here room needs to be
made for reflection born of religious
traditions
in vain you worship me teaching
the doctrine doctrine the commandments
of
men you have made void the law
by your traditions
they are the repository of centuries of
experience and wisdom here again he
places tradition above the word of god
this is a very dangerous encyclical
for these reasons the church
while respecting the autonomy of
political life
does not restrict her mission to the
private sphere
church and state church and stay
together on the contrary she cannot and
must
not remain on the sidelines in the
building of a better world
or fail to reawaken the spiritual
energy that contribute to the betterment
of society
it is true that religious ministers must
not
engage in the party politics that are
the proper domain of the laity
but neither can they renounce the
political dimension of life
itself the church will
dictate and they make the distinction
between laity and
hierarchy again that's unbiblical too
and william ball said the same
exactly and he constantly says
it involves constant attention to the
common good and the concern
for integral human development
this encyclical sets the stage
for what is coming upon the world
we don't have to read at all but it's
interesting
the church has a public role over and
above her charitable
and educational activities she works for
the advancement of humanity and of
universal fraternity this is the issue
she does not claim to compete with
earthly powers
but to offer herself as a family amongst
families this is the church
open to bearing witness in today's world
open to faith and hope and love for the
lord and for those whom he loves with a
preferential love a home with
open doors the church is a home with
open doors because she is a mother
she's the mother of all the churches
she is the great of babylon
upon her for it is written mystery
babylon the great
and then he introduces paganism by
saying for many christians this journey
of fraternity also has a mother whose
name is mary
having received this universal
motherhood at the foot of the cross she
cares not only for jesus but also for
the rest of her children
now fatima promised that the whole world
would be at the feet of the roman
catholic church well let's say mary at
fatima
it's interesting that they called it
fatima and
it brings of course the muslim world
into union with the catholic world
but be that as it may i think we've read
enough of this
encyclical to get the point i want to
point the viewers
to this book ecclesiastical megalomania
by john robbins it's a very fascinating
book and if you want to know more about
catholic social doctrine and the
economic principles of the roman
catholic
church and you would be wise to read
this book i just want to read one or two
statements here
which might interest you he quotes here
monsieur john ryan the roman catholic
architect of the new deal and of course
there was a jesuit
and it says but constitutions can be
changed and non-catholic sects
may decline to such a point that the
political prescription of them
may become feasible and expedient
what protection would they have then
against the catholic
state that's interesting
the latter could logically tolerate only
such religious
activities as were confined to members
of the dissenting groups it could not
permit them to carry on general
propaganda
nor accord their organizations certain
privileges
that had frequently be extended to all
religious
corporations for examples exemption from
taxation as an example
the church will rule in 1948
the jesuit cavalier explained
roman catholic state political strategy
in la saville catholic
it says the roman catholic church
convinced
through its divine prerogatives of being
the only true
church must demand the right
of freedom for herself alone
because such a right can only be
possessed by truth
never by error in a state where the
majority of the people are
catholic the church will require
that legal existence be denied to
error and that if religious minorities
actively exist they shall have only a
de facto existence without opportunity
to
spread their beliefs sure this
is jesuit thinking if you belong
to some group that believes the bible
that believes that jesus is the only way
to salvation
that believes that the word of god is
the norm and standard
for your life that believes that the law
of
god in its entirety all ten
commandments is binding you will be
an anathma in the eyes of this church
ayn rand was right when she wrote in
the catholic church has never given up
the hope
to re-establish the medieval union of
church and state
with a global state and a global
theocracy
as its ultimate goal
he writes further the roman church state
in the 20th century
however is an institution recovering
from a mortal wound
this is biblical language from an
economist
if and when it regains in full power and
authority
it will impose a regime more
sinister than any the planet
has yet seen
and if people still do not believe us
let us just go through a few papal
statements
to show that this encyclical is
absolutely in harmony with papal
thinking
and has nothing to do with fraternity
and brotherly love
it has to do with megalomania
and power hunger
i find it very interesting my young
brother
that archbishop quigley in 1903 in the
chicago tribune
wrote the following when the united
states rules the world
the catholic church will rule the world
and that is why the battlefield is in
the united states of america
and the ideology which will eventually
surface there when this thesis and this
antithesis
let's say biden and trump clash
will produce the synthesis that has been
prepared
and already implemented since the 2002
7 and 2008 economic crash
but let us just go to some statements i
just want to say on that
that it's also a biblical language
the image of the beast will give all its
power to the
beast absolutely according to canon law
the control of
all property of the roman church state
belongs to the pope its supreme
emperor it's very clear
these are statements this comes from
thomas reese inside the vatican the
politics and organization of the
catholic church harvard university press
the economic thought of the roman
catholic church
private property thomas aquinas wrote no
treatise on economics
but his thinking based on that of
aristotle
very interesting not based upon the
bible
just like francis is foundational for
understanding the economic thought of
the roman
church state this is the growth of
economic thought by henry
siegel roman catholic economic thought
as developed by the popes in the
encyclicals and by roman church state
councils has been a contributor to
feudalism and guilt socialism in europe
during the middle ages
fascism in italy spain portugal croatia
and latin america in the 20th century
nazism in germany in the 20th century
interventionism and redistributive state
in the west including the united states
in the 20th century
liberation theology in latin america and
africa in the 20th century
and now we're heading for the climax
thomas aquinas discussing private
property
the possession of all things in common
is the natural law
thomas wrote the possession of all
things in common and universal freedom
are said to be of the natural law
because to wit
the distinction of possessions and
slavery
were not brought in by nature but
devised by human reason for the benefit
of human life
let's see how it continues the community
of goods
wrote thomas is ascribed to natural law
not that natural law dictates that all
things should be possessed in common
and that nothing should be possessed as
one's own
but because the division of possession
is not according to natural law but
rather arose from the human agreement
which belongs to positive law
hence the ownership of possession is not
contrary to the natural law but in
addition they're too devised by human
reason
they always write in this way they write
in this way to this
very day exactly so that's a common
person shouldn't
understand what they are saying but it's
actually sounding as if you're just
continuing continuing reading the babson
secretary
absolutely he writes
hence what certain people have in super
abundance
is due by natural law to the purpose of
suckering the poor
did we just read that yep we just wrote
that
we just read that in the encyclical
okay he writes further because the goods
of some are due to others by natural law
the goods of some are due to others
there's no sin if the poor take the
goods of their neighbors
okay so in other words you can break the
commandments of god that's fine
i've seen my neighbors got some nice
things maybe i can go
in cases of need all things are common
property so that there would seem to be
no sin in taking another's property for
need has made it common
so who determines the need my young
brother well according to this
you yourself you determine and the
church will help you
to determine it right yeah not only
is such taking of another's property not
a sin
it is not even a crime according to
thomas
it is lawful for a man to sucker his own
need by means of another's property
by taking it either openly or secretly
noiseless properly speaking theft and
robbery it is not theft properly
speaking to take
secretly and use another's property in a
case of extreme need
because that which he takes for the
support of his life
becomes his own property by reason of
this need and a case of
like need a man may also take secretly
another's property in order to sucker
his neighbor in need
now in the united states and in many
countries around the world we've had
riots
and looting and 99
of the time the looters get away
scot-free and the owners
are sitting crying because their goods
have been
redistributed without consequence
so you don't have to question anymore
why that happens that when people
take something of somebody else yes
nothing happens and why you should
actually defund the police
get rid of them because everything is
common
you have no right to have something in
super abundance now if you have a store
full of things
that's really a super abundance how
about just looting the store
that's fine no consequence the church
says it's not a sin
the roman catholic doctrine of private
property is echoed in the 19th century
communist slogan from each according to
his ability
to each according to his need
so human rights are more important than
property rights
it was the creed of lyndon johnson's
great society we shall take from the
haves and give to the have-nots who need
it so much
it appears in the literature of fascism
nazism
liberation theology interventionism and
socialism
this is what the bernie sanders people
and
all of them are all about this is roman
catholic doctrine
now john paul ii who is such a hero in
the united states at the moment
expression of his 1987 encyclical on
social concern
it is necessary to state once more the
characteristic principle of christian
social doctrine
the goods of this world are originally
meant for all
the right of private property is valid
and necessary but it does not nullify
the value of this principle
private property in fact is under a
social mortgage it doesn't belong to you
[Music]
it belongs to everyone which means
that it has an intrinsically social
function
based upon and justified precisely
by the principle of the universal
destination of goods
so who owns everything the church
and nobody else owns anything not even
governments no
the church owns everything everything
if you go back in history and you go to
the map of south america
where the pope took his finger and said
this belongs
now to my good country portugal
this here belongs to my good country
spain
if you do not tow the line i'll take it
away from you and give it to someone
else
he'll put his hand over czechoslovakia
and say
well the czech republic and say this no
longer exists
because a young host dared to sway the
populace away from rome
that country that economy won't
exist pope paul
vi did francis just quote him
yes each man has therefore the right to
find in the world what is necessary for
himself the recent council vatican 2
reminds us of this god intended the
earth and all that it contains for the
use of every human being and people
thus as all men follow justice and unite
in charity created goods should abound
for them on a reasonable basis
all other rights whatsoever including
those of property and of free commerce
are to be subordinate to this principle
you don't own anything and just on the
previous one with
john paul ii um
it looks like maybe trump is
now against all this the
property and everything belonging to
everybody but like you said
he endorses john the poor john paul ii
absolutely absolutely and here
he quotes if one is in extreme necessity
has the right to procure for himself
what he needs out of the riches of
others
that's exactly what thomas aquinas said
these people are not saints they're
criminals in the eyes of god
and we label them or the church labels
them
saint therefore because private property
is immoral all men individual
and governments have the moral
obligation to redistribute goods held
unjustly by property owners sure
interesting right john paul ii says
all goods includes not just goods found
in nature but
manufactured goods as well
so you don't have a right to your tv if
someone else has need of it
or your motor vehicle nothing hijacking
everything is permissible no wonder
society
is in the state that it is in they have
made
void god's law this
system is called by god
lawlessness the man of sin
the man of lawlessness this is what he
is
he makes void the law of god and sets
himself up
as the moral value system of the world
in the name of the very one who is you
who
is usurping of his power jesus
absolutely and i get very passionate
about this
and i would just also again like to
reiterate
don't think yeah but this is the pope
and this is the roman catholic church
it's just
nothing you just heard in the previous
episode
biden and trump uplift this
institution yes and not only that the
groundwork for the implementation
implementation of these things has
already been done
so this is not a philosophy somewhere on
the horizon
this is at the door and this encyclical
that you've just been
going through acknowledges also that
that
rome has not changed rome has not
changed one iota
and this encyclical by pope pius rerum
nevada on the condition of the working
classes
one of the roman church's most
influential statements on the economic
matters
is the night 1891 encyclical rerun of
on the condition of the working classes
nothing has changed
this encyclical comes from 1891. every
pope has quoted it
in this encyclical the roman church
state allies itself with the protellerat
with which in marxism is the great and
final
enemy of the capitalist order pius
writing in 1931 declared that the rerum
novarom
stood out in this that it laid down for
all mankind unerring rules for the right
solutions of the difficult
problems of human solidarity called the
social
question this is pious writing
in cuadra gesimo another
john the 23rd wrote and he quoted
and this is the pope that started
vatican 2 remember
by far the most notable evidence of the
social teaching
and action which the church has set
forth through the century
undoubtedly is the very distinguished
encyclical letter rerum novarum
i want to say to you today that the
encyclical which pope francis has just
released
couched in this buttery flowery language
is nothing other than a rehash of
rerumnovarum
issued 70 years ago the norms and
recommendations contained there in were
so momentous
that their memory will never fall into
oblivion
and pope francis has just made pretty
sure
of that he told us that the encyclical
namaram was instrumental in ending
fair capitalism in the 20th century by
ushering in the era of effective
interference by government you have no
privacy
and haven't they taken that to a new
level that they've taken away your
privacy
yes it's in your pocket every single day
when you carry your phone with you
yes and now with the covet 19 look at
the surveillance
absolutely no privacy no privacy
this is from the book ecclesiastical
megalomania that i'm quoting now
he says was the voice of moral authority
needed to ensure the development of
effective interference by
all governments in the 20th century
pius xi wrote it is not surprising
therefore
that under the teachings and guidings of
the church
many learned priests and laymen
earnestly devoted themselves to the
problem
of elaborating social and economic
science in accordance with the
conditions of
our age so who fomented
the violence in the world the church
and now they use the violence
to implement their system under the
guidance and in the light of leo's
encyclical
novaram that's almost 130 years ago yeah
was thus evolved a truly christian
social science which continues to be
fostered and enriched daily by the
tireless
labors of those picked men whom we have
named the auxiliaries of the church
i wonder who these picked men were is
that the men
running the politics of the world yep
430 years already
and who constantly is standing by their
side
their jesuit guides and prelates
nor were these the only blessings which
followed from the encyclical the
doctrine
of nuvarum began little by little to
penetrate amongst those who being
outside catholic unity do not recognize
the authority of the church
the kings of the world will give their
power unto the church
unto the roman catholic system and
it's going to happen and these catholic
principles of sociology
gradually became part of the
intellectual heritage of the whole
human race
thus too we rejoice that the catholic
truths proclaimed so
vigorously by our illustrious
predecessor leo
xiii are advanced and advocated not
merely in non-catholic books and
journals
but frequently also in legislative
assemblies and in the courts of justice
the bidens of this world the bernie
sanders of this world
they are speaking this language those
picked men fascinating language
secret societies conspiracy theories
our friends will have a field day about
conspiracy theories
so john robbins sums it up
and he asks the question who are those
picked men
he says those picked men we have named
the auxiliaries of the church
quoting what the pope had said who have
been so
instrumental in ending the free
enterprise system of the 19th century
and substituting a system of effective
interference in government in the 20th
century
who those picked men are
i do not know well i think
we are watching those picked men
speaking on our television screens
every day yes pius
wrote in his encyclical
under fascism property owners may keep
their property titles indeed
but the use of their property as leo
the 13th wrote is common
this is exactly what pope francis said
fascism is a form of socialism that
retains the forms and trappings of
capitalism
but not its substance under fascism
property titles and deeds are intact
but the institution of private property
has disappeared you appear to own the
land
you appear to be on your own
vineyard but ahab says i want it
and jezebel says i'll get it i'll give
it to you and if he doesn't want to move
i'll kill him that's a very interesting
scenario government regulations and
mandates have replaced it
for this distinction between legal
ownership and
actual use the fascists owe a debt
to the roman church state that's out of
the mouth
of the roman catholic system
when we speak of the reform of
institution the state comes chiefly to
mind
not as if universal well-being were to
be expected from its activity
but because things have come to such a
past through the evil of what we have
known
termed individualism
that following upon the overthrow and
near extinction of that rich
social life which was once highly
developed through associations of
various kinds
the social policy of the state therefore
must devote itself to the
re-establishment of the industries and
professions
let's put that in a nutshell we want to
go back to the middle ages
that's what it says and it talks about
the extinction of that rich social life
which history turned the dark ages
this is where we're heading yeah but
worse
the experiment with economic freedom
pious the 11th road must end
and economic life must again be
subjected to the planning
and government so now having discussed
the latest encyclical
of the pope which comes after
laudato si where we have the care
of the environment and the introduction
of the concept of rest as determined by
the roman catholic church
we now add the fraternity and the social
structure
then you have the moral directive and
you have the social directive
and it's the dictates of the roman
catholic church
may god give us wisdom as we come to
this system
which and i want to end with repeating
the statement
that we read in john robbins
where the author states what we've read
already
the roman church state in the 20th
century
let's make that the 21st century
however is an institution recovering
from a mortal wound
if and when it regains its full
power and authority it will impose a
regime
more sinister than any
the planet has yet seen
this is on page 195
of this book may god grant
humanity mercy and may they find
refuge under the wing of jesus christ
so that they may understand what true
liberty
is all about it is bound
up in his law it is
bound up in his law which is a
transcript of the character
of god and grants you
rights which they with impunity
will remove from you let's pray
heavenly father we are heading for the
very final moments of earth's history
we are in very serious times
and there is only one solution that is
left
because i know lord that the kings of
the world will give their power
unto this beast and the solution
is the rock cut out without human hands
that will
strike the statue and bring the systems
to an end so that not even the dust
will remain may that day come soon
in jesus name amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you